this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by helix
upstart honey and expressvpn more on
that later let's get into the do
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here
doing it in studio night pants i'm ryan
sickler
ryansickler.com ryan sickler on all
social media
uh just a huge thank you for all your
support we just finished a hundred
episodes uh we're about to kick off the
first of the next
uh hundred so i just wanna thank you all
for your support thank you for making
this such a fun show thank you for all
the messages
the emails everybody i i sincerely
appreciate
uh your support and we're going to keep
on doing the damn thing so
get over subscribe to the youtube
channel you'll get audio here on mondays
video on tuesdays don't just watch
subscribe
and uh you're going to get some more
content coming soon there as well
um if you're a fan of the time codes if
you look in the description underneath
youtube
you'll see uh stories you can jump to if
you'd like
the patreon show is growing thank you so
much for your support there the honeydew
with you all
i'm doing the honeydew with you all out
there i've heard some amazing crazy
funny
stories um if you or someone you know
has a story that has to be heard please
submit at honeydewpodcast
gmail.com we're going through all of
them we will get to you
there are a lot we're going to keep on
doing that show too so
um if you're on board for it you can
subscribe for a year save yourself some
money
i know that that five bucks a month is a
lot for some people
60 a year uh a lot of things going on
out there but you can subscribe for a
year and you'll save
over a month of of episodes you'll get
them for free it goes back to you y'all
so
uh subscribe to that as well uh the
facebook fan page make sure you're
subscribed
over there for updates clips all that
stuff make sure you're following me on
instagram can't thank you guys enough
for the itunes reviews as well all that
stuff helps man you guys are the [ __ ]
uh the honeydewpodcast.com is the
website for the show
all the merch is there it's also on
ryansickler.com but the night pants are
there
the the night panthenation champion
sweats are there the hoodies the
t-shirts for the honeydew the t-shirts
for
for my uh ryan sickler the fist pump
uh i say pump fist bump uh shirt the
appreciations
really cool design uh upstate merch is
the [ __ ]
zach newton is designing some of that
stuff for us over there so thank you um
and i record here at the santa monica
music center you know i like to give
back so if you live in la if you need
musical instruments you need musical
lessons this is the spot for you or your
kids do
take a lesson with your kids go to santa
monica music dot com you get online
lessons use the code honeydew
and they will waive the registration fee
and they'll give you one free lesson
when you sign up for
a package all right that's the biz
um if you're new here on the next
hundred shows what we do over here is we
highlight the low lights these are the
stories
behind the storytellers we're shedding a
little light in that darkness
and laughing uh in the face of adversity
and uh this guy is no stranger to the do
ladies and gentlemen excited to have him
back the saga
continues joey diaz welcome back to the
honeydew joey
great to have you what's happening there
ryan i'm saying you look so
good jersey looks good on brother you
look like an old
suave gangster out of vegas right now
and in his twilight years coming into
his own you look good dude you do
it's tremendous it's a different life i
got the stink of l.a off me
my daughter's the school she's happy and
for the followers of the show
yesterday was the 33rd anniversary of
the kidnapping of kent vela
november 18 1987.
really so yesterday was the anniversary
yeah how many years
80 70 30 33 yeah i called them tuesday
night
oh every year he's unemployed now so he
wants to hear from me
you talking about full circle man
[Laughter]
you know i apologize to him
i did a bad thing i apologized to him he
accepted it
and we became again that's great so i
i called him tuesday night left him a
message i was thinking about him
i go 33 years ago tonight i was planning
on what to do with you
so
all right let me say this for uh for
those of you listening because a lot of
people
have missed that the the last episode of
that i i actually was
honored to uh host uh guest host the
church
and that's the episode where we cover
the kidnapping so there's a lot of you
like hey there seems to be a
a chapter missing that's where you find
that chapter okay go to the church of
what's happening now
check out the episode i guess hosted and
that's where joey tells that whole story
this time
exactly where we left off was february
of 1989
uh it was you were just leaving prison
and what you said is it was the first
time in the halfway house which made me
laugh because that means it's not the
only time you're in the [ __ ] halfway
house
when i think of my stent at bcpc
and what does that stand for joey bctc
older uh community treatment center okay
boulder county the same people who own
bctc
owned ldpc which was in longmont
colorado
about uh 20 minutes away okay
you didn't want to get you know they put
you the way you were
from but they threatened to put me in
longmont at first
and i didn't mind because there was a
little mexican place out there
called the delicioso and they made the
best [ __ ] breakfast burritos
you've ever had in your life i'd put
away like eight of them
damn eight nine of them that they were
that good
like so i didn't care about going a long
month but i really wanted to go to
boulder
you know so i found out i went to
i went in you got a three-day
orientation
you can't leave you could call your
loved ones
they could bring stuff in the clothing
you need
you know whatever you need for your job
and then after three days they let you
go out
just to find a job okay so let me
let me ask you some questions because we
had this halfway house right next to my
middle school
and one of my um high school wrestling
coaches worked there later in the years
he he'd take us home in the van
he dropped but we couldn't get in you
know you can't get out he has to get out
of the van and let you out we're like oh
yeah this is a correctional van you
can't get out of this [ __ ]
but so you're now you're you're out of
prison but you're at this place where
how many people would you say are also
living under this roof
90. oh wow okay that's way bigger than i
thought it was
the case so you got 90 all men three
no the bottom floor was women and then
the two top laws were men
okay and it was uh seven man rooms
and then when you moved up this system
you got put into a three-man room
so you're my coach experience
go ahead after after three days you're
allowed out
for about a week to find a job from like
nine to five
uh you have to call them and let them
know where you're going
so i got to call them and go i'm going
to ryan sicklers
to interview at goodyear and then from
there you have to have a list for them
so i would just make up a phony [ __ ]
list
of where i was going and then uh
those three days were kind of shaky but
then once you got i got a job right away
doing what and then
i think the first job i got was like a
detailer at a car lot
and but those first three days
when you know they they hold you for
three and then that first day when you
they let you out to go get a job
i
get back on the board here you know what
i'm saying i'm down by 10.
something's got to be done here i'm you
know i forget getting a job at eight
dollars
at eight dollars an hour i'm not getting
no job for eight dollars an hour
so i started slinging where i got an
ounce of coke right off the [ __ ] back
the fourth day out the fourth day out
that's why all that [ __ ] you talk in
prison
is [ __ ] i'm gonna go out i'm gonna
read the bible
the fourth day out the first place i
went to was my buddies
to get an ounce on the arm to go to work
let me ask you
what the card feels like what did it
feel like though to be
just out you know you're now i'm
including to have you're
you're on your own you i know you have a
you have a curfew
but what does it feel like that first
feeling of after all the [ __ ] you've
been through you're
you're actually breathing the outdoors
right now there's not
someone watching you when you're walking
or driving or taking the bus to your
friend's house
i knew that at that moment i was never
going back into prison
i did know that i did know
that i was a criminal i came to that
conclusion
and i figured out that whatever i did
from now on i had recovered to it
and i had to keep it low you know
it would be small moves selling
coke was the alternative i mean i could
sell coke all day long
so just to get on the board i started
slinging coke
like the third the fourth day just to
put some money in my pocket generate
some income
you know move around and then i got like
a job
i really don't know ryan i would be
lying to you
if i told you what my first job was i
can't remember
but i got a job right away and i still
remember bringing the coke into the
halfway house with me
i was gonna ask like that takes okay
and i still remember weighing it
in the bedroom on the top bunk
and i still remember one day that uh
like in my first two weeks
the chick that ran the place did a
surprise attack on me while i was
weighing the coke
and i had it in like a big i had it in a
big binder when i put it in
the coke flew all out to the bindle
but it was still it was in little chunks
so she walks into the room
i got the scale hidden like [ __ ] uh
uh richard gere an officer and a
gentleman i had it up in the ceiling
i had everything hidden in the ceiling
but she comes in
and there's still all these little coke
rocks on the carpet
and she goes you guys need to do some
carpeting and we got to get the
maintenance guy to come in here
and vacuum the dust off this stuff she
thought it was [ __ ] dust
from the ceiling she didn't know that
there was an ounce of coke
you know on the [ __ ] floor in little
chunks
you know that this is what i walked into
i mean
you create this life for yourself
so that that was it off the bat then i
got a job
but i kept slinging coke
and then eventually i started snorting
code
and i walked into the into bcpc
maybe in february and by april i already
gave my first hot ua
so the first one is free the first one
is you get
locked up for 14 days you're only
allowed to go to work
no leisure no gym no nothing
so i figured out a different idea
instead of getting a job
i went to my buddy's garage he had a
garage where he fixed cars
and i would hustle details there but i
got a pager
so they didn't know where i i was
they could also drop into your job i
made it that
i was driving cars back and forth so
don't come in here because i'm never
going to be there
ryan it was just a different level yeah
they weren't even ready for me
like they weren't even ready for the
game i was imposing on
they could shake you down at any time
and you couldn't have more than 40
on you oh really okay
yeah you had to pay it was uh
at that time it was 75 a week rent
and you also got a box of food
like frozen swans and dinners you know
uh cheese slices shitty food you know
for the week
i used to get food delivered
i'd get chinese food delivered and they
lose their [ __ ] mind
like i showed up just completely
different like i was running my own game
in there
then i gave them the hot your analysis
and then they were really on me and that
was just once you give them a hot you
wear
just coke i wasn't smoking dope or
anything
once i gave the first hot i came to the
conclusion that i can't snort coke and i
was fine with that
but i still needed to sell coke to make
some money
the job was just to cover
the other thing i devised was you had to
pay rent on thursday
but everybody got paid on friday so if
you didn't pay rent on thursday you
wouldn't get your legion time on the
weekend
that opened up another afternoon for me
loan sharking
so i would lend out 75 bucks for 102.
so i can give you 75 on thursday you
give me 102 on friday
i was a one man [ __ ] wrecking crew
you got 27 profit on that [ __ ]
yeah i had 10 of those [ __ ]
every week
so i became i became a long shark
i was slinging coke and i was hustling
whatever the job i was doing
now wait are you also selling coke to
people
in the halfway house are you just hiding
it there
i'm hiding it there but i'm also selling
it to people
at the halfway house you are so they are
all doing it so any of them could
to give a hot test then all coming from
the coke oh yeah
oh they were they were all i had a
couple guys i was selling it to
once i got the first hot ua i had a
garage i rented
about eight blocks away on 16th street
i paid 35 a month and i had a hot a
heavy bag in there
and a a bar way before i got arrested
i kept that little gym so i started
stashing my coke in there
it was only a walk away so i would stash
it in there
have the scale in there so i'm loan
sharking in there i'm slinging
coke i'm [ __ ] around and then guess
what happens i give him another hot
ua even though i wasn't doing coke
just touching it oh okay i wondered yeah
handling it just wait because the guy
would give me like
six ounces at a time and it would be
like
four chunks and a half ounce of powder
this [ __ ] mexican was a nut so
i would have to pick up these chunks of
coke it was like [ __ ]
his coke was real it was [ __ ]
tremendous
so from weighing it it went through my
skin
and then i gave my i gave him another
[ __ ] hot ua
so now that we're gonna put me back in
prison try to hire my attorney
to go in there and fight for me you know
they had me on lockdown i couldn't leave
the building
then they came to a conclusion that i go
to a rehab
and i just mentioned the name of this
rehab the other day i forget the name of
it
it was from six to nine at night
five nights a week and you had to sit
there
and guess what i went to this rehab
for i think it was six weeks three hours
a night
five nights a week and i started selling
more coke at the rehab than i ever did
like it was [ __ ] crazy
that would be like 12 people in the
group
and you know like nine of them were
still getting high
so we're still getting high in there but
then something happened
i got a [ __ ] call one day that i
knocked up my girlfriend
oh okay and this is what year are we at
right now
90 are we in 90s so 89
we're in 89 okay we're in like
may of 89 i'm already in the [ __ ]
rehabs
and now this poor girl tells me she's
pregnant
had to be about june so now i had a
i had a [ __ ] strap the belt down a
little bit harder
and i stayed clean and i went and sold
the hot car at the time was the eclipse
by mitsubishi oh yeah
so a friend of mine said that he needed
help at his place
selling mitsubishi's so i went over
there and i started making eight nine
grand
a month selling mitsubishi's i would
just sell eclipses
i wouldn't even look at the [ __ ]
because the eclipse is hard to get
and you made like 800 of the car
because you sold them above sticker
price
so now i'm [ __ ] selling cars
selling coke loan sharking
i'm a one-man wrecking crew
i'm getting watches sent out from new
jersey
rolex watches presidentials
the guy was given to me for like seven
grand i would sell them to ten
i was it was the prime for joe i was
doing
more hustling in those months than i
ever did before like it was the top of
my hustle game
i was uh 27 years old
28 and i was making probably
15 grand a month damn
between the selling cars the selling
coke i wasn't
snorting so it was all profit you know
this is 15 grand a month and 89.
oh yeah i'm [ __ ] slinging with both
hands yeah
and then they moved me into i started
making progress in the system
i started becoming a model prisoner
oh my god i turned it i [ __ ] i just
i turned it around i [ __ ] really
turned it around it was just amazing
they were blown away no more hot uas
i was doing everything i was supposed to
do i was on my best behavior
i had the best summer of my life you
there
i'm here brother i thought i thought you
were froze up for a second
i had the best summer of my life selling
cars
i didn't do coke the whole summer but i
was just the [ __ ] renegade man
i was just a [ __ ] renegade in there
and then i got them to uh
i got them to so high that
they gave me a furlough
like a four-day furlough to get married
and to go on a honeymoon
but i had them at that time
and i did my program and they let me out
they said you're done here really we're
gonna put you on regular community
corrections
yeah so once you get married and come
back
get your stuff and get out and then you
just don't
you still got to go to meetings and
circle jerks and all that [ __ ]
so so by august
of 89 i was a free [ __ ] man because
you're married
because i'm married i get married i move
into my place
wait sorry what month do you get married
uh september of 89
but you officially are because you're
getting married you actually get out
before the wedding
i get out they said like a week before i
got married they go
you know by the way your time is done
your time is done you could do your last
six months from the house
so that's what i had like six months
left but you could do it from the
comfort of your own home as long as
you're married because you have a family
okay okay gotcha i had done my time
in there i've been there from february
it was now september and it was seven
months and they were like
you came in here with like a 16 month
sentence left
something weird so the last eight months
you could do on house probation
hell yeah so i was still on community
corrections i still had a pee in a
bottle
i still had to do all that stuff
i get married i'm clean everything's
fine
but my buddies come out for the wedding
and they give me a package at the
wedding
so i do a couple of bumps at the wedding
and you're not stopping me
oh i know what i got on the plane i'm
[ __ ] up
you know i'm drinking on the plane
uh i get to san francisco she falls
asleep
and i go out to see a friend of mine
because i lived in san francisco in 85.
so i went looking for a friend of mine
he gave me an eight ball
i stayed up all night in the garage
doing it with a [ __ ] eight pack of
beer a six pack of beer
i walked upstairs at seven i got in bed
and she woke up
and we went on a honeymoon like you know
we went to a uh
we went to an oakland a's game with
conseco
and all those guys yeah and then monday
monday night we went to monday night
football
opening game the giants at the niners
oh that's great yeah
but i came back on tuesday and i had the
bugging me dawg i was back on the power
so i started doing powder i i
worked against the clock i would snort
on friday nights
because i could possibly can't clean by
monday
you know i could be clean by monday were
your tests
random at this point or did you work did
you know when they were coming
they tested me monday wednesdays and
fridays damn
so you had to call a number at one
o'clock
and the number would tell you what color
was up
and there were some mondays where they
wouldn't text me so i played against the
clock
i would get high on fridays because if
you didn't test me on monday
chances were you gonna test me on
[ __ ]
on wednesday but if they tested you on a
friday
that means you were gonna get tested
again on monday okay
so you always had to play the clock yeah
and i did it great
then they started nailing me on mondays
and that's when i went to work
i would i would like if i called that
one
and my color was up i would go to
albertsons and buy a bottle of vinegar
a white vinegar distilled vinegar 32
ounces
and a bottle of gatorade and i would get
a package of certo
cerdo is what you use to make like a
jello
okay yeah and i would drink the whole
bottle of white vinegar
no dude with gatorade
you would mix 32 that's [ __ ] four
cups of vinegar and gatorade mixed
what does that taste like i would drink
[ __ ]
you know when you're a [ __ ] junkie
this is what happens when you're a
junkie doesn't that burn your face
ah oh just destroys your insides i got
away with it like maybe twice
so wait i'm sorry i'm gonna interrupt
you again but this is what
this is supposedly a a concoction that's
gonna neutralize this test or give you a
negative test
this is the word on the street got it
that you had to drink vinegar but at the
end of the day nothing works
they always get you it's some type of
metabolites or something
so i got away with the test like maybe
two times
and then maybe like mid-october they
[ __ ] nailed me
they nailed me again and instead of
rehab
they said you're going back into the
halfway house
you're gonna do an extra [ __ ] group
meeting and like you know
i was i went from being the model guy
to the [ __ ] schlub
so i would wake up every morning and
walk to my apartment i walked about i
lived about two miles from the halfway
house
i would walk to the apartment see my
wife
get changed and go to [ __ ] work
and that that really made me
become a little bit like i did you know
just a realization
of what i had done and stuff i'm like
god damn it
i can't get my [ __ ] life together
and i started working to i still sold
coke
you know i wasn't doing it
i said let me just do this steady you
know and i
i stuck to the program i went to the
[ __ ] aaa meetings
you know i did everything i had to do
uh
the holidays came i was great
and then i got myself up to level four
which was unheard of that was unheard of
like
a lot of people didn't make it to that
top tier that top tier
let you stay out till midnight
and it gave you two furloughs a month
so you go home on friday and come back
on sunday night
okay twice i was that good and and i got
my driving privileges
oh wait you weren't you weren't allowed
to drive before that
no but i was driving i didn't give a
french [ __ ] i remember
i remember being on the light one day
i remember being in the light one day
and one of the counselors pulled up next
and i'm like [ __ ] but it was funny those
months when i was a junkie
i tormented their [ __ ] world ryan
because i couldn't figure out how to
beat the drug test
so i started [ __ ] getting like
chlorine
for a pool and i would grind it down
into a powder
and i would pull the skin back on my
dick and sprinkle the chlorine on my
helmet
jesus christ and then pull the skin back
and then put like a [ __ ] rubber band
on my dick
and i would pull this
so i started [ __ ] around with that
test
they couldn't figure out what the [ __ ]
was going on they're putting chlorine
in the test oh man but doesn't that burn
the [ __ ] out of your dick
your stick skin is so sensitive [ __ ]
pool cleaner pool
cleaner yeah i know i was a lifeguard i
know what you're talking about i feel
like that would burn
your weeks i was
i was grinding down it was tremendous
it was really tremendous i was
i was grinding it down into a [ __ ]
powder
and putting it on my dick and i was
[ __ ] with them
and then one week i used drano
come on it was tremendous it was
tremendous
i was driving these two it was a team it
was a man and woman team
that would test you and then they also
when you're level four they also have
the right to come to your house whenever
they want knock on the door
and check your house your refrigerator
smell around to see if there's weed they
knocked on my door ten times you know
how many times i open that door
zero i don't open the door for strangers
zero listen to me i would turn the tv
off
they would come back with a sheriff's
car and sit outside my door
for two three hours i would outweigh the
sheriffs
i'm not going anywhere
uh zero
my attorney would call me you gotta open
the door for them no i don't they don't
have a warrant
well they have this from the court [ __ ]
that [ __ ] i gotta see a warrant
i know my rights i'm like jay-z i know
my rights you gotta show me the [ __ ]
warrant
let's take a quick break and tell you
about our first sponsor honey now
imagine this you make a list of the
gifts you're gonna buy for the holidays
right and then someone randomly
gives you the money to help buy one
sound good well that's what honey is
doing they're helping pay for 1 million
dollars
worth of gifts all right you're probably
wondering is this the same honey that
automatically searches for promo codes
online
yes yes it is with honey you can also
make a list of the holiday gifts you
want from certain stores and honey will
email you when the price drops on
anything
on your list you just add honey to your
computer you create a free account and
you throw some holiday gifts on your
drop list
for a chance to win honey will randomly
select winners
and give them the money to help buy
something on their list all right
i'm looking for some stuff for my
daughter right now i got out of this
bill nye
virtual reality thing where you can do
all these science experiments virtual
reality since you can't go to school now
you can still feel like you're really
doing this stuff
there um any gifts you want
you put them on the list and honey will
give you a heads up all right there's no
purchase necessary you need a paypal
account to redeem the prize
only valid in the u.s and the giveaway
ends 12
21 2020 get honey for free
at joinhoney.com honeydew once again
honey is free and you can get it at
joinhoney.com
honeydew our next sponsor is expressvpn
now when you use the bathroom you always
close the door behind you right i hope
you do
you don't want random passerbys looking
in on you so why would you let people
look in on you when you go
online using the internet without
expressvpn
is like going to the bathroom and not
closing the door
did you know that your internet service
provider like comcast or verizon they
know every single website you visit
and what's worse is they can sell this
information to ad companies
and tech giants who will use your data
to target you
expressvpn puts a stop to this it
creates a secure encrypted 10 tunnel
between your device and the internet so
that your online activity can't be seen
by
anyone i use expressvpn on all my
devices it works on everything
phones laptops even routers so everyone
who shares your wi-fi can still be
protected
even if they don't have expressvpn and
the best part is that using expressvpn
is as easy as closing the bathroom door
you just fire up the app
you click one button boom you're
protected expressvpn is the world's
number one rated vpn by cnet wired the
verge and
countless others so if you're like me
and you believe your online activity is
your business secure yourself by
visiting expressvpn.com
honeydew today use my exclusive link
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com slash honeydew and you can get
an extra three months for free that's a
lot
three months that's expressvpn.com
honeydew now let's get back to the do
that [ __ ] was banging on that
door
and then uh something weird happened
i went to my coke dealer's house or was
it dear friend also
and he asked me if i had ever seen this
comedian
and i go what are you [ __ ] talking
about and he goes this comedian andrew
dice clay
and i go no and i saw that that had to
be november of 89
and i saw that special and my head blew
up
yeah like i kept watching it and
watching it and watching it
and then for new year's eve i was in the
halfway house
so i talked them into renting the
conference room
and having a party for new year's eve
non-alcoholic
showing the andrew dice clay special on
vhs
and i got like [ __ ] pizza brothers
and tomatoes
and they let me do it and i watched
andrew dice clay
and uh 1990 they let me out of the
halfway house
february 2nd of 1990
on a friday my then wife
picked me up pregnant as can be
ready to bust she picked me up we went
to a restaurant called lucilles
it's still in boulder [ __ ] tremendous
it's cajun
oh i love cake i got the uh i got the
three eggs
with the redfish and the bayonets
with these [ __ ] potatoes
it had it was february 2nd it had to be
60 degrees out brother
we got back to the apartment about four
o'clock
i think i watched the news and i must
have passed out about seven
and i woke up february i just let me out
of the halfway house
i wake up february 3rd to a woman
yelling
okay and it was my ex-wife that her
water had broken
okay and she was like you know we got to
get out of here i'm about to have this
baby
i [ __ ] jump in the shower i'm getting
ready
i go outside and a foot and a half of
snow fall
had been sleeping i didn't even see the
snow yeah so i go hold on one second
i gotta unshovel the [ __ ] car so i
get the car i shovel it
i shovel the spot as best as i could
i you know i had the car running i back
up the [ __ ] car and i pull it out
just to get her to come in and the
[ __ ] guy who lived upstairs
came with his car and pulled into my
spot after i had just shoveled it
i just got out of the halfway house i go
this isn't happening
so i go up to the guy i go dog what are
you doing
my wife is pregnant inside i gotta pull
around and he said some snide remark
and you're not [ __ ] getting off this
easy move your [ __ ] car
and he goes i'm not moving my car and he
spit on my car
whoa so i just [ __ ] i punched him
right in the [ __ ] face
and here my wife is inside
and i'm fist fighting some dude in the
driveway
between between you and me ryan's second
this guy had me
he clocked me like three times straight
and he kind of had me
and i and but he slipped on the ice
and i jumped on him and started beating
the [ __ ] out of him i'm pounding him in
the head
and next thing you know i look up and
there's three cop cars coming at me
i'm like i'm never gonna make it i'm
never gonna make it out of this [ __ ]
system like i'm
i'm a dead man
so the cops pull up next to me you know
i run up to the cops i know one of them
and i'm telling the cop what happened
they go we got a report
of a woman yelling like we got a report
of a [ __ ] like a woman
getting domestic violence well what the
[ __ ] is going on here like there's no
my wife is inside yelling because the
water broke
i'm out here i shovel the [ __ ] thing
look where my car
is and this guy just sneaks his way in
so that i'm like i'm dead i'm going to
go to prison for the rest of my life
they have a talk and the cops decide
they go listen it was just a
misunderstanding
why don't you guys just apologize to
each other your neighbors
you're gonna have to [ __ ] live with
each other i'll never forget the cop
going
put your hands out and shake hands the
guy goes
i'm not shaking his hand and the cop
looks at me goes you know what
we could just get back in the car you
weren't doing too good when we got here
you better shake his [ __ ] hand look
at your face
the cop with the dude is all banged up
and he wouldn't shake my hand
and the cop told him you weren't doing
too good when we got here you know what
i'm saying
so you better shake his [ __ ] hand
so the cops actually give me a they gave
me an escort to the hospital that's nice
so i got my wife in the car drove it to
the hospital
had the baby she's in the hospital i go
home i get an 8-ball
to celebrate you know me dog old habits
never change now even though i'm free
i still owe them like
eight more months of piss test and
that's when
my world began i just started [ __ ]
blowing up their machines
every time i go in there for a piss test
i would throw something else on my dick
to [ __ ] that machine up
bromo salsa alka salsa
you must have like a leather dick i tell
you man
i don't think i could handle any of that
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
oh that's so good [ __ ]
[ __ ] alka saucer that's how deep
my uh my whatever ran
i had a little girl um
you know man this is why i tell people
nothing's gonna change you unless you
change yourself
amen i'm sad i've sat i've sat with men
thousands of times you know doing
[ __ ] an ounce of coke
telling me i love my kids this is the
last time i'm gonna get high
you you'll never see me again after
tonight you know
kids can't stop you from getting high
probation can't stop you from getting
high
nothing can stop you from getting high
when you're gonna get high you're gonna
get high
people don't realize that i know the
other side of it
i think back to my times that time
period of my life
it didn't matter and you know what made
it worse ryan that i
they gave me a rule i couldn't get high
i don't do well by rule right
you know we're comedians that's why we
became comedians
because we cannot follow society's rules
no
i could i wake up every morning at five
in the morning
six seven eight i'm an early riser
i'm on social media at 7 30 in the
morning you know
if i had a job i wouldn't wake up at 8
in the morning
when i have to do something i'm not
gonna do it
there's no way you know i've been on my
own basically since i was 10.
my mother again when i got out of
captain school my mother made me an
offer i couldn't refuse
i'm gonna let you do it your way the
first time you [ __ ] up
you go back to my way so looking back at
it now
i could handle rules
when i when they dropped that whole
program i
stopped getting high as much i noticed
that
because i had a [ __ ] rule and i can't
follow rules
i i live i i do what i do why i do it i
don't know
and i'm gonna keep doing doing it that's
just the way i am you know
that's my malfunction that i can't obey
rules
i couldn't live on the society standards
that's my malfunction
but at that time
i was already thinking about stand up i
just didn't know how to start
and how old i just had no idea 1990 how
old are you now
i'm 27 years old okay so this is just
starting to think i can stand up at 27.
just starting to think about it still
working you know
at this time i probably had three jobs i
was working at a car dealership
i was you know selling cars from the
paper
like if you had a car for sale for 5 000
i would offer you 42 cash
fix the car up a little bit and sell it
to 6 000.
you know i was [ __ ] hustling my ass
off
at this point at the age of 30 i was a
[ __ ]
and then my family asked me if i want to
go work for them
they were moving their roofing operation
from new jersey to colorado and they
were looking for laborers so i said yeah
i might as well go work for family
you know i didn't want to sell cars
anymore
and i caught on really quick to roofing
it was flat roofing it was uh rubber
roofing it's called ballasted roofing
it's flat roofs with rocks on it you put
rubber down
insulation and then you ballast it with
rocks
and you frame the stuff with the metal
whatever you call it i don't i don't
know
so i got into that and my whole thing
was to get on stage
i was such a [ __ ] [ __ ] ryan i mean
you know
because i knew that
i just i i roofed
i had sold stuff
i had worked in restaurants as a
bartender
i did [ __ ] everything and there was
nothing i really liked
you know and when i got into the roofing
and then i got promoted to an estimator
so i took like a good year seminar i had
to take a carlisle seminar
anybody who makes rubber they would
invite me to their seminars my company
would pay for me
to go to their seminars and then i
actually took a
uh a class on how to estimate
you know construction's cost and all
that stuff
so i became an estimator and i really
enjoyed it
but something was missing
i bought a condo i had a truck
i had a car i
was married i had been in prison
i had to fight the odds i got out of
that [ __ ] pro you know how i got out
of that program
wow i was working out i was working at a
car wash
as a host and right before i got into
roofing
i used to talk to a guy once a week he
would come in
and just talk to me how you doing what's
going on i would talk to him
and one day after like six months i go
what do you do
and he goes i'm the district attorney
and like are you bill wise and he goes
yeah
the real district attorney was alex
hunter but underneath him was bill wise
the reason why i mentioned these names
to you are they were involved in the
john bernay ramsey stuff
years later okay what's his name was the
mayor and bill wise
was the d.a and he was forced to resign
over the john bernay thing but i gotta
tell you he was a good man
he was i talked to him every day for a
long you know
i talked to him once a week we would
have conversations while i was out there
and when i told him what i had done i
got in trouble
with the whole bella thing he goes that
was you and we started talking and
giggling
and uh he goes just have your attorney
put the motion on my desk i'll sign it
behind the other da's back the d.a that
prosecuted me yeah
he said [ __ ] him he goes [ __ ] him
i'll sign and he signed it i was let off
i think november of uh
of 90 okay i was done with my sentence
everything was done everything now
you're done
you could snort all the coke you wanna
do whatever the [ __ ] i want
but something wasn't right something
wasn't right in me
something just didn't feel right i was
making money
i had everything that america
society tells you you you need
to move forward i had everything in the
palm of my hand
but something wasn't what right brian
cichlid
so this is it this is [ __ ] it
i work five days a week on saturday i
watched a kid because you got to work
and then on sunday we go to your parents
house to eat
and i start all over on monday and then
one day when i'm 65 you give me a gold
a gold watch and you tell me
my years of service were great that that
was it
something wasn't right just something
didn't seem right
so i searched my answer was religion
so i started going back to church i got
confirmed
i remember when i got thrown out of
catholic school right before my
confirmation
so i said i said what i need is the holy
spirit
to be complete so i went i got confirmed
that the classes at night i made my
confirmation
i was still [ __ ] miserable so i went
to naropa institute
my friend was at a restaurant at naropa
institute it's a
it's a college in boulder for buddhists
it's accredited you know you go there
and get a degree in philosophy you're
going to end up a [ __ ] waiter
with dirty feet but you know it's
you know it's i took a couple classes
and i really enjoyed buddhism i i liked
it i liked the principles
i took a monday night class on walking
meditation you know the whole thing i
was
i was looking for something something
was
[ __ ] missing something wasn't right
you know
and that march of 91 it snowed
and i went to one of the job sites we
were working at
and the guys were like bro our [ __ ]
labor didn't show up today
and we have nobody go get us food can
you go get us food and i was like [ __ ]
yeah
you know it was a diner around the
corner and they had green chili
i was hungry anyway i'll go let me go
over there
and get the green chili and when i was
they had like boots
and then they had like a you know like a
bar like uh it was an old school diner
yeah and when i sat at the bar there was
a denver post a rocky mountain
news the newspaper
you know how sometimes you just take a
newspaper and open it
yeah well when i i just i remember doing
that back in the day yeah
like just opening it not the first page
yeah just like the middle right to go
right to the sports kind of thing
i did that i opened up the paper and
in the paper the front page i opened was
an
ad roseanne had just blown up
so the denver comedy scene was blowing
up
and there was an ad about the denver car
it wasn't an
ad it was a write-up about the denver
comedy scene
and what had happened since roseanne
blew up
how many more comedians were going to
how come the club became more popular
the denver comedy works and then at the
bottom it said
are you thinking of becoming a comedian
and it told you
the options to do and they had an ad for
a stand-up comedy class
at the university of colorado in boulder
it was right
up the corner from my house it was three
sundays
it was 38 bucks and it was taught by a
guy named jeff harms
i'll never forget that guy he was a
stand-up comic
and he was part of an intro improv
troupe
oh somebody got stabbed in los angeles
it's not a fire department it's a
[ __ ] helicopter
so he got uh
what the [ __ ] we oh he was part of an
improv troupe
it was three sundays from one to four
he just broke down stand-up comedy and
blah blah and then the last week you had
to go up
in front of everybody and
the last week i went up i don't know if
i got any laughs or not
it didn't matter i just wanted to go up
you know
and uh
when i got off before class ended as i
was walking out
he came over to me he goes what's your
name and i go joey
and he goes i usually don't tell this to
the students
but you have a career and stand up if
you want to
and i was like what are you talking
about he goes
you could do this i could see it you
could do this and i was like
i'm a roofer you know i'm married i'm
dead
yeah i just took the course just to see
you know
and he goes if i was you i'd look into
it and he goes here's my phone number
stay in touch
and about two days later he called me
and he said that a new club was opening
up and they were looking
they were looking for doorman to
he'd get me a job as a dorm man that
club's name
was uh wits end comedy club in
westminster colorado it's no longer
there
it was like a sea room you know
and i started a job as a doorman there
and i remembered that like that april
you know in colorado
even though it's not winter sometimes
you get snow yeah
like it'll just snow a foot and a half
in april
and i'll never forget that that april it
snowed
and i didn't have to work that day so i
went and rented
the movie with tom hanks
about stand-up comedy yeah sally field
and tom hanks and
yeah sally i watched that and i just
went over the [ __ ] top
like i'm like i gotta do this [ __ ] i
wasn't happy at all
something i had everything i wanted that
you're supposed to have
as an american that's 28 years old
uh i was a felon but i wasn't letting
that stop me that wasn't gonna get in my
way you know
and i worked the door for a few months i
asked comics questions
you know nobody was around today i just
asked stupid questions and i kept asking
questions and asking questions
and i kept calling the comedy works to
get on their open mic
and every two weeks they would call me
back and go
uh mr diaz you got a three-minute spot
on tuesday
and then on tuesday i would call and
cancel
why scared every time they get petrified
yeah i went through a couple months of
that [ __ ]
i'm just canceling and you know
canceling
canceling i'm gonna write my [ __ ]
story i would never write
you know i gotta get it down and then
one tuesday
or one week in july my ex-wife heard me
call up the comedy works
or she heard them call me and say you
have a spot next tuesday
so without telling me she got the a
babysitter
so she forced my hand so it was july 16
1991 it took me 16 months to get the
courage to go on [ __ ] stage
and i remember just driving down the
comedy works
i i had no idea what i said
but i remember going up on stage
at that time i had done everything you
know i had done heroin
i had done coke i had you know
when i walked off stage i can't describe
the high i had
yeah like i wasn't stoned i wasn't on
cold i wasn't
that whole day i didn't do anything this
was my moment to see if i could do this
or not
like for me july 16 1991
was my turning point when i got off
stage the owner of the comedy works the
time
it was wendy yeah but it was also a guy
named ed nichols
came up to me ed nichols came up to me
and he goes you got a really good stage
presence you should really stick this
out
and the guy pj moore came up to me and
said what are you doing tomorrow night
i got a gig can you do five minutes
and i was like yeah i could do five
minutes
and i got the [ __ ] gig let's take a
quick break and tell you about our next
sponsor helix now
i've been on the road a lot i've slept
in a lot of places i've bounced around
my whole life and i'm
telling you there's nothing more
important than a comfortable mattress i
had a
i had a friend of mine whose grandma
said to me one time
spend good money on a bed because it's
where you rest your soul
and i'm telling you that's never been
more true than now all right i got the
helix mattress i got the midnight lux
this is the best mattress i've ever had
man i have it in my daughter's room
we go in there got the queen size i read
to her we both fall asleep but i'm not
even supposed to fall asleep i have work
to do
and i'm in there passing out because
it's so comfortable helix sleep has a
quiz okay you can take this quiz
it takes two minutes to complete and
matches your body type and sleep
preferences
to the perfect mattress for you
everybody's unique and helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and firm mattresses
mattresses are great for cooling you
down if you sleep pot and even a helix
plus mattress
for plus size folks i took the helix
quiz i was matched what i already said
the midnight lux mattress because i
wanted something that felt
like a medium firm and i sleep on my
side
okay i love it like i said it's a huge
upgrade over what i used to have
and i'm tell you and here's the good
thing is you don't have to spend a ton
of money
to rest your soul helix has you covered
the delivery
and setting up was fast and easy it's
soft but it's still really supportive
i'm falling asleep right away i'm
sleeping well
my daughter loves it everybody's into it
so if you're looking for a mattress you
take the quiz you order the mattress
that you're matched to and the mattress
comes right to your door it's shipped
for free
you don't ever need to go to a mattress
store again helix is awesome but you
don't need to take my word for it helix
was awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick
of 2020 and by gq and wired magazine
so just go to helixsleep.com honeydew
take their two minutes sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life
they have a 10 year warranty and you get
to try it out for 100 nights risk free
that's a no-brainer
all right they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will
helix is offering up to 200 off of all
mattress orders
and two free pillows for my listeners at
helix sleep.com
honeydew that's helix sleep.com
honeydew our next spot is upstart you
know we love upstart i love upstart you
guys love upstart
so many of you have hit me and use their
service and i absolutely
am grateful for you and i'm glad you're
loving it because there's a lot of
economic chatter right now about the
state of the market is it recovering how
long will it take
have we seen the worst but if you're
struggling to pay off high interest
credit card debt
you can't wait for those answers you
need to take action now with upstart
there's actually something you can do
today to help fight off high interest
credit card debt
upstart is the revolutionary online
lending platform that knows you're more
than just a credit score unlike other
lenders
upstart can reward you based on your job
history in the form of a smarter rate
upstart lets you skip going to the bank
because it's completely online they
offer loans from a thousand
all the way up to 50 000 so you can
consolidate your debt into one easy
fixed rate payment
upstart makes it fast and simple to
check your rate since it's just a soft
pool
it does not affect your credit score the
hard pull happens
if you accept your rate and proceed with
your application and the best part
is if the loan is approved and accepted
most people get their funds
the very next business day over 500 000
people use
upstart to pay off credit cards or meet
their financial goals like i said you
guys are using it i know you are
um it's it really does help you don't
pay that
insane high interest these credit card
companies got bailed out years and years
ago
and they're still hitting us with high
interest no use upstart free yourself
from the burden of high interest credit
card debt
and get back to using your money your
way with upstart see why upstart has
over six thousand five star reviews on
trustpilot and hurry to upstart.com
honeydew to find out how low your
upstart rate can be checking your rate
only takes a few minutes
that's slash upstart.com
now let's get back to the do i i'll
never forget on the drive home
like what was going through my mind like
this is it this is what i want to do but
i'm dead
i can't do it it's very hard to tell
your wife that you want to get into
stand-up comedy
for a lifetime free when you just had a
baby
when you just have a child it was i was
dead
yeah so whatever dreams i had were dead
they were really dead it was like uh
that i was really [ __ ] broken in half
you know i'm like what do i what am i
gonna do now i'm stuck being a [ __ ]
roofer and estimated nothing wrong
with it it's a decent job it's better
than being in jail
but i really wanted to do the stand-up
and i just
it was like and i got on stage like
maybe three times that july
maybe three times that august
and then something just wasn't right
still
that feeling came back so
my wife at the time told me you have
money saved up
maybe you need to find yourself go home
i had i hadn't been in new york for six
years at that point
i hadn't seen my friends in six years
i came home for a week snorted coke
was out of real i remember they gave me
a police car at the hertz rental
they gave me like an old they rented me
a car but it was a detective car
and i still remember going to the bronx
and people like nah
we ain't going to deal with you
[Laughter]
that crown vic car yeah it was a crown
vic so i remember going back home and
just feeling empty
like i'm never going to be able to do
this [ __ ] dream
you know yeah i get on stage
here and there but all these guys talk
about the road
and you you know you hear bob sega
talking about the road
and bon jovi talking about the road and
you know something just wasn't right so
i kept living my life i kept estimating
i kept
selling cars and then
there was this nissan truck that opened
up somebody told me
they had a nissan truck for sale but i
already had like two cars tied up i
already had like
eight grand tied up in two cars
and i had like four grand laying around
upstairs
but i was still three grand light
so i ran a scam when i was at the
university of colorado with pell grants
and [ __ ] scholarships and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i knew you know i got every [ __ ]
latino scholarship that was ever made
poncho video everybody sent me five
everything everybody sent me yeah
everybody sent me 500
that went right to the coke dealer you
know what i'm saying so
i said how can i come up it was like a
[ __ ] scam
so i went to the boulder i went to
university in colorado i went downstairs
and they had like a loan office and i
went in there and i said listen i got
i got some credits i owe you i want to
go back
and they go well it's too late to get a
pell grant
it was right there in september right
there when you
sign up for pork semester so i said let
me just get a loan
and they said fine and they gave me a
loan i
signed up for the classes once i got the
loan
i bought the car they gave me a loan for
26.25
the standard loan
i bought the car and i sold it the next
day for a 2 000
profit so i just went back and paid off
the loan
okay they were like what what the [ __ ]
is this
you know like and i did it again and
then i owe them and i never paid it back
and my my wife now made me pay it back
she did for real
yeah i took another loan out how much so
let's work on 26.25 you paid it all back
yeah oh i had no choice they just
[ __ ]
they'll never a certain amount of money
those [ __ ] come back at you and
they they just take a judgment on
i didn't want a judgment so i just paid
it off but
so i took this loan and i paid it off
three days later
and i withdrew from the school okay
i paid my bills and i never thought
nothing of it
this is the beginning of september okay
i never thought anything of it again
i'm struggling uh i'm struggling
as a human being like with this comedy
and you know being a dad and
being a roofer i'm struggling with all
this
and one day i get home at five o'clock
and my ex-wife is in the kitchen and
when i turn around she goes do you have
a minute
it was october 15th of 1991
and she holds up the loan
and she goes what is this she goes i
just got this in the mail today it's a
receipt
you took a loan out without letting me
know and i'm like
at that point in my life i was doing a
thousand things that nobody knew
you know what i'm saying i didn't know i
had to ask permission from
my business i didn't know so she's like
i feel like that's
lying and i want to get separated
and it was like just a rush came over me
like
somebody just did me the biggest favor
of my [ __ ] life
i thought about my daughter who at the
time was 18 months old
you know she told me she was in a movie
with a mom
just to see how she felt and that we'd
revisit in a few months
and uh
ryan i almost fainted really
i almost fainted because it was like
somebody had
done something for me that i wanted to
do
i really wanted to give this comedy [ __ ]
a try like i was dead
serious about it and i i never forget
that she packed up and left that day
because of that loan
that night yeah but it was
it wasn't alone yeah i'm sure it was a
long
it was a long time sure the loan was the
straw that broke the camel's back
you know i talked about it on my podcast
this week that
like two months or three months before
we broke up
we were eating dinner one night and she
said to me she goes
i don't understand if you understand
what you did
she goes you took a man handcuffed him
and put him in the back of a [ __ ]
trunk do you know what type of person
does that
and she was right i mean ryan let's you
know yeah i was out of control
i was totally out of control you know i
didn't see it at that time
i was chucking and jiving but i think it
took her like three years for her to
sink in
what i had really done you know
and who she had married you know and
she had made a mistake you know i
actually took a guy i had no
problems with that at all you know that
was just
another day in our life for joey diaz
you know but that's the truth i mean
at that time in my life i had been on an
eight-year roll
and if you think putting somebody in the
back of a trunk of a car was bad
you missed my asking day you know you
missed all that other [ __ ] you know
but i think that you know she thought
about her kid
she looked at a kid and said what type
of man am i
is going to raise my child you know i
was a different person then
that's why i take the different lives of
joey diaz you know
um and she left
but it was so weird that night i went in
the paper
and i saw that the broker the broker was
a bar in boulder
they were four bars they had four they
had restaurants the broker was a
restaurant
but in boulder it was more of a pickup
bar on wednesday nights they had like uh
a professional's night and
people went there but tuesday nights
they actually did comedy night it was a
steak night
15 bucks you got a steak a
salad and you got to see a [ __ ]
comedian
and they were running the best broker
joker
bex has a beer you know beck's beer
you know in the 90s what a lot of people
don't understand was there was no
netflix
there was nothing like that the exposure
you got was from doing contests
there were certain contests you did
johnny walker had a contest
there were more national contests hbo
had a contest
everybody had contests nbc had a contest
i remember going to an nbc contest
signing up and waiting
i had never been on stage before and
like two people before me
i just left i just [ __ ] laughed
because some guy in front of me had like
a comedy club jacket on i'm like
these guys are pros i've never been on
stage before i'm just gonna go up there
and bomb
i still remember going into an audition
for charlie hill
charlie hill was at the university of
boulder and then we were looking for
local comics to come in
and i had to walk into a room with like
three students in there
and do my [ __ ] stupid jokes
the guy the three guys looked at me like
what are you you're the worst comedian
we've ever seen
but it was so weird i went down to the
broker
and i became part of this contest
that started like september but they
were having like
prelim rounds right october november
with the finals being december 8th
18th 1991
the winner got 500 bucks
and i just invited my friends from
boulder
and i went to the contest and i kept
winning
every week the rounds i kept coming in
first place
like it was like every other week i had
to go down there
and then i could hang out and watch the
comics you know i was going to the
comedy works in time
and doing three minutes down there and
uh i was doing the the broker and that
that that was it
there was not a lot of comedy rooms at
the time but that's where
it was just born in denver
yes it started in denver and then uh
december 18 1991
what i was doing was i was selling
valiums at the time
all right just straight up
so all these coke all these coke guys
are telling me hey
we want to buy valium and i would go oh
if you want volumes you got to come to
the broker
i'll be at the broker like what the [ __ ]
are you doing at the broker i go i'm
doing comedy
and they're like we didn't even know you
did comedy i'm like yeah you know but
how many volumes do you need and they're
like 20. like all right meet me at the
broker
in those days what i was doing was
stocking the audience with my friends
they didn't know they were gonna have to
pay and sit they would get there and go
we're here to see joey and the guy would
go you got to sit down and pay
so i would have like 20 people there but
they weren't there to see me they were
going to buy drugs
i would just tell them meet me at the
[ __ ]
brokers sell you drugs so i was stalking
every time i did a content like
let's say you call me on sunday you
wanted valiums for the week
i would hold you off till tuesday and
then make you
come to mind and then come to my show
so i would have 30 people in there the
night of the contest
there was maybe 118 people in there
and i had 90 people in there i couldn't
lose
i couldn't lose even if i wanted to
because they they based it off of the
applause
okay so i won i won the broker joker
i won the 500 but the house emcee
was a magician that was always drunk he
was the worst magician in the world
so i talked the owner of the of the the
general manager
of the restaurant to let me host on
tuesday nights to get rid of the
magician
i go look how many people
kevin is a magician he was
he was an old magician yeah you know he
he hosted all of the events that they
did
like they did up they did like movie
night on sunday nights
he just came with the white yeah he came
with the place yeah he was
he was an old white guy he was out of it
so i actually went up to this guy and
asked him i said can i host here
look at the amount of people i bring
every week every time i perform i got 90
coke fiends in here
[ __ ] drinking drinking 18 cocktails i
was selling tickets
even before i was known you know nobody
[ __ ] knew who i was
i was packing the place because i would
tell them come down
i'll have your drugs for you down there
so they made me the [ __ ] house emcee
january the first week of january of
1992
i already had a job as a comic i was
getting 50 a show
yeah so that's 200 a month and [ __ ] in
my world that's a [ __ ] start
yeah 200 a month plus all you could eat
or you could drink and that's how i
started [ __ ] comedy right there
that's how i got into it
a lot of people don't know that [ __ ]
stuff i didn't know that
i didn't i won the broken joker i don't
know why i felt like your early days
were seattle
no seattle came in 95. so
this is still 90 this is 91
going into 92. okay 92
was fantastic i was an open miker i had
my own night on tuesday nights at the
broker
i was single i had every credit card
imaginable i had never used a credit
card in my life
i didn't believe in them but now i was
single i could do whatever the [ __ ] i
wanted to
and i was just doing comedy using credit
cards that's
it january
a girlfriend caused a lot of problems
and that's when the problem started with
my ex because me and my ex were cool
from november to like january we were
cool
everything was great and then she told
me
she moved in with a guy with my kid so
i'm like you told me not to date nobody
because we're catholics
the divorce is finalized and here you
want to move the guy in with you
in three months so i started getting
yeah what the [ __ ] but this is all
i know plan this is all this is all
planned so
uh this is what happens when you're a
loser
and you can't provide as a man you know
i wasn't a family guy
at all i was you know i wanted to do
comedy but that's the transition into my
comedy career that's
how i transitioned it took me 16 months
i was [ __ ] petrified
i didn't think i was good enough to do
it and i knew that if i failed
that was it there was nothing else
for me was it going to be a puppeteer
what was i going to do with my life
there was nothing else
i had already been a salesman i worked
them
yeah i had done everything this was it
when i got into comedy i got into comedy
knowing that this was it there was no
other options
i was too old for the army i was too you
know i had been a
i was a felon i all my possibilities
were cutting that
so at that point i didn't know
what i was really involved in i was just
getting on stage
every week i was reading the judy carter
book
and in those days there used to be a
comedy newspaper
that came out of san francisco they just
interviewed different comics and they
told you about what was going on
and i just remember reading that every
week i would go
and get it from like when i would go to
the comedy works or something
i'd pick up a copy of it you know i had
all those newspapers saved
and i would say in the back i had a club
thing
of all the clubs in the country and the
one-nighters
and i would [ __ ] circle all those
things and just cry
and [ __ ] say one night i'm gonna play
the punch line and see
in san francisco yeah one you know
once i'm gonna be up in seattle you know
at the underground
i like their logo it was kind of weird
that i like seattle comedy underground
logo so i kept thinking to myself i'm
gonna be in
[ __ ] seattle someday you know but i
had no idea what i was doing
i was just getting on stage at the
broker and i kept doing that
until i got fired i got fired december
of 93 by that time
i had lost everything you know i was
just
you know when you become a comic you
don't want a [ __ ] day job
i was hustling i was selling neon i was
selling some valiums
i was dabbing some coke but it was just
basically to stay alive
you know pay child support
and do [ __ ] comedy but
at that age you know i read the book by
lenny bruce ladies and gentlemen
lenny bruce you know and it was just
about doing drugs
and going out every night and that's
exactly what i did
i just that's what i wanted to do it was
about
getting high getting on stage and in
those days there wasn't a lot of comedy
in denver
i was doing poetry readings what
i was doing you had to sneak in as a
poet so i would put like a little hat
with an
apple on top and i'd walk in
into a coffee shop and [ __ ] i wish there
was a video of that [ __ ] somewhere
oh my god the the famous coffee shop was
called penny lane
in boulder it was penny lane
and i would go to penny lane it was open
24 hours
coffee shop couches you know books that
type of stuff
a bunch of intellectuals you know and i
would go in there for the eight o'clock
poetry reading
and they would throw me out every week
stop stop you can't talk like that in
here
i'd be talking about godzilla and
[ __ ] killing chinese people and [ __ ]
on stage
and they're like you can't you can't do
that this is
but there was one manager who uh
who worked the midnight shift to eight
in the morning
and her boyfriend was in the halfway
house with me
so she saw me there one night and she's
like you know we do a poetry reading at
midnight
from midnight to about three every
morning and i go are you [ __ ] serious
and she goes come night come down you're
always welcome
so i would have to wait till midnight to
do the poetry readings
and again they would you know i'd have
to follow a guy like that was up there
i ran i ran and i ran into the
wilderness
and then i'd go up there because i would
[ __ ] heat
talking about hitler and [ __ ]
oh god oh
that's the kind of i'll tell you one
thing i do miss as a comic
right now about live shows is sitting in
the back and watching
you know everybody else go up and do
their thing you know i miss it he's my
fungus that's
one of my favorite things just sit back
in the cut and watch people get up there
and rip it up and just die laugh and try
and do
[ __ ] all of it man that's great that's
so funny
you know i was i was yeah i was i was
separated
i was heartbroken on my kid i was kind
of heartbroken over the divorce
but the [ __ ] comedy just filled the
gap
i couldn't explain it to people 20
something years later like
it made me get over everything like just
the fact that i was doing comedy
but i was part of it you know uh
and like i said the first year i pretty
much stayed out of the comedy works
because the boulder opened my the
boulder show
was the same nights as the comedy works
open mic
so i was off the radar there was one kid
there was a kid named jimmy abeda
and there was a guy named uh i always
give this guy props
because john payton something paid andy
peyton
andy payton was his name he really uh
andy payton was a comic with the mind of
of a he's a mayor of a town now in
colorado
but andy got sick and tired of not
getting booked by clubs
there was three clubs in denver at the
time
and they wouldn't book you know a lot of
crazy people
then so andy would
book his own seven nights a week he had
a room
and he created a comedy newspaper and he
would sell ads
to the to those rooms that he would do
the comedy at
it was a brilliant concept so i learned
comedy from hustlers at the time these
guys jimmy abayda and andy payton
were just [ __ ] hustlers they would
walk into any bar
and go what do you do here on tuesday
nights nothing
what kind of budget do you have to work
with 150 [ __ ] it we'll do a comedy show
i had lana gets 100 everybody else gets
to go on stage
and he takes home 50 bucks and
everybody's happy
you know so i came from that mentality
there was no comedy clubs there it was
uh mckelvey's
wits end and the comedy works
and they wouldn't give me you know they
weren't giving me no guest sets or
nothing
i was just fighting for my [ __ ] life
but i was doing a lot of drugs
i was [ __ ] out every night you know i
had a girlfriend after a while
then she moved away and i was single
again
and i just went off the deep end and
then
uh in december that because i pretty
much that
that that broker that i did comedy at
i just took it over they had a hotel
there
i would get free rooms i would go in
there and eat lunch for free every day
you know i just took they made the best
rice krispie treats
you ever had in your life and they had
them for lunch
that does sound good i'm the [ __ ]
buffet
so i would go in there every day and eat
i was just causing
pandemonium in that place and finally
one night
on a tuesday night in december a manager
said something to me
and i looked him straight in the face
i'm like do me a favor go [ __ ] yourself
and he's like what did you say and there
was like before you got into the bar
there was a lounge that had a lot of
books
that you could sit there and get a
brandy and just read a book if you want
to
who the [ __ ] goes to a bar to read a
book but you know you know people are
these [ __ ] gentiles
so i looked at him and i pushed him and
he [ __ ] knocked over a thing of books
and i got fired from my open mic gig but
i gave him 14 good months
it was my first comedy job so i was
making money from day one in [ __ ]
comedy
yeah uh i pushed him
i was barely making ends meet at that
time you know
i was living in my friend's house and a
room
i was paying child support and
my attorney fees were just starting to
go through the [ __ ] roof
and then uh i did christmas i did new
years
i totaled my car
i didn't total my car i [ __ ] up the
rim
but it was one of those cars where each
room was twelve hundred dollars
so i actually had to go to the lot i'm
not gonna
it a lot because then people will know i
had to go to the lot
in the middle of the winter in the dead
of january
i had to go to the lot jack up a car
steal the tire off it to replace my
[ __ ] rim
you know i was just living like a nomad
then i remember going home one saturday
night and
i bought that new car i didn't buy a new
car i bought a
a slightly used car like you know after
you get divorced
you give away your truck and the family
car and you buy a hot rod i bought an
acura integra
beautiful with a tremendous sound system
and i financed it through this bank and
i had a bank account at this bank
you know the whole [ __ ] deal and one
night i go home
and i'm i'm dead broke i got no dough
and i got to do a line of coke and i
found the you know this
any credit card when you get a credit
card they send you those blank checks
yeah and discover i had like three
discover checks
and that bank had a 24-hour drive
through
and i just wrote a check for a thousand
bucks to cash
at the discover card was closed for
christ's sake
the discover card had been taken from me
already
i gave the lady a check and she cashed
it no
they gave me a thousand bucks [ __ ]
monday more
monday morning 901 they called me
and they said if we don't have our money
by five o'clock
we're gonna press charges on you
i didn't have the [ __ ] money i had
spent the money an hour
so i went down to the bank and cut a
deal with them to add it on to the car
principal and then
i didn't make the car payment for three
[ __ ] months
and that was great when the tow truck is
following you and you see them following
you
yeah so you you've got to hide your car
like rambo with camouflage
and [ __ ] trees you got to shake them
and [ __ ]
[Laughter]
when you look back you think of all this
[ __ ] you're like what the [ __ ] was i
thinking why would i even
stick it out with something that there's
no money in
like there was no money in county back
then no i was just doing comedy i was
just loving it
and i was getting on stage every night
and i finally
had a call my brother whose wife just
recently died
about two months ago after i got here
i called him i told him what my
situation was
i told him i couldn't make rent
because i was losing the wall with my
wife with the kid you know
and he sent me a plane ticket back to
jersey he goes come back
so i came back whatever that date was
for the super bowl i was back in jersey
but before i left i went to the valium
guy
and i fronted like ten thousand valiums
i told him i'd be back on that i told
him i'd be back in an hour and i brought
the values back here with me
to start my comedy career up here as
finance
so that's what we'll leave off january
of 93.
i'm writing it down hold on january
1993 is where we pick up
i love you brother thank you for doing
this
thank you for having me brother always a
pleasure to see you i miss you with all
my heart uh
i miss you you know i'm not mad at los
angeles like i told my wife that i went
to lunch
and i go i don't ever i'm not mad a lot
of great things happen for me in l.a
and i got to meet a lot of great people
and you're one of them so thank you bro
thank you and i'm happy we continue the
saga
we'll keep it going whenever you're
available my friends
so i couldn't really go off oh yeah
we'll wrap it up
next time next time we do this
i'll cover the [ __ ] holes in this
story there's more excitement in this
story
but i got the fbi upstairs
i love you brother uh as always november
november 25th november 25th
ozzie's boneyard all right 12 o'clock
uh eastern 9 00 a.m pacific
and then every day after that till the
30th
the boneyard plays hopefully they'll
keep me and they'll let me do one show a
week and uh
i could do my heavy metal stuff you know
what i'm saying yeah i know it brother
that's great
good for you well i love that that's
what we're trying to do
i love you brother thank you for having
me of course thank you for having me on
the honeydew
a shout out to all you patreon
[ __ ] i love you
and that's it all right as always ryan
sickler.com ryan sickler on all social
media we'll talk to you all next week
[Music]
you